moi je pense que c'est on est dans le
maquereau nisme toute opposition est
insupportable sans raisons sont les
sachants et lorsqu'on aborde le
capitalisme de connivence on nous savons
de quoi nous parlons
on sait que vinci n'a pas eu notre dame
des landes
c'est très bien que vinci fait tout pour
avoir aéroports de paris on sait très
bien que le président macron lorsqu'il
était ministre voulait déjà cette
privatisation qui l'a fait celle de tout
ce qui a été un échec et donc lorsqu'on
met ce gouvernement devant ses
responsabilités assez secret neige c'est
insupportable et je maintiens c'est un
capitalisme de connivence
regardez dans les cabinets et les
personnes qui ne travaillent qui ont été
embauchés que sur ces questions là donc
je maintiens c'est un capital i de
cogner est ce qu'il ya une forme de
menace aussi on entre les lignes de la
part de l'exécutif lorsque c'est ce
genre d'arguments qui est évoquée la
suppression du sénat qui revient au
détour d'une dune d'examen d'un projet
de loi c 'est pas anodin c'est pas
anodin c'est en gros rangez vous sinon
sinon c'est de la suppression du sénat
écoutez
il ya des personnes plus à l'est que le
brillant mâcon qui essayait de
s'attaquer au sénat et ça c'est pas
toujours très bien passé et aujourd'hui
les français s'aperçoivent qu'une chose
il n'ya qu'une opposition au
gouvernement c'est de senna est
aujourd'hui les sénateurs se sont
comportés en contrôleur du gouvernement
c'est un partout ça fait partie de leur
mission quand on contrôle le
gouvernement ne sont pas d'accord avec
le gouvernement sur ces privatisations
non seulement nous avons le droit mais
lorsque nous dénonçons ces
privatisations
on n'a pas nous faire un chantage en dix
ans faites attention vous allez
disparaître c'est quoi cela vous rendez
compte
j'ai rarement vu dans un hémicycle des
menaces ouvertes
on sent un gouvernement aux abois ils
n'ont rien à dire avec le run leur futur
grand débat la sortie du grand débat où
il pouvait mettre au grand débat la
privatisation d'un des pays n'ont pas
fait vie donc aujourd'hui sont aux abois
un dernier mot un dernier mot pour
évoquer cette initiative de
parlementaires est venu de la droite et
de la gauche pour proposer un référendum
d'initiative parlementaire ce serait le
premier et vous seriez déjà 197
est ce que ça peut être la solution pour
sortir de ce dossier de privatisation
d'alépé c'est la solution je pense que
on aurait dû dès le début sur un sujet
aussi sensible consulter des français et
des moyens de le faire
consultez des français est donc là ce
référendum d'initiative partagée par 197
parlementaire vous avez entendu que
certains n'avaient pas signé et on dit
dans leurs interventions qui signerait
et ensuite il faudra quatre millions et
demi de français qui signe cette demande
de référendum
je vous prédis la la le résultat de ce
référendum à plus de 80 % des français
sont opposés
on vend les bijoux de famille en france
et ça c'est inadmissible